fate has not always been kind or indeed
amable to the lib dems visiting a school
in the marginal constituency of lewis
though Nick Clegg seemed to feel right
at home can you come with me for the
next few days or become painful his hope
is an emphasis on education will help
the party back into government preparing
to commit them to real terms increases
in school funding but only once the
books are in balance our manifesto will
hardwire fairness into British society
memories memories the 2010 manifesto
launched here in the City of London was
a big moment for the Liberal Democrats
unheralded at the time it ended up as a
blueprint for key parts of the coalition
government's program that both partners
now want to claim credit for so the lib
dem idea of boosting the personal tax
allowance pretty much George Osborne's
favourite policy today similarly the
pupil premium implemented in government
now a foundation the lib dems want to
build on if you want promises that you
can trust this is a manifesto for you in
a positive way the manifesto set the
tone for five years of government but it
is remembered not just for what was on
the front cover but for a little-noticed
pledge on page 39 that they would scrap
unfair University tuition fees for all
students saving them over 10,000 pounds
each to think that one sentence could do
so much damage so to avoid scenes like
these if they get back into government
the lib dems manifesto majors on the
tried and tested again a more generous
personal tax threshold education we know
about additional health care funding to
and all with more detail than either
labor or the Tories are offering about
where the money comes from so much has
changed then Nick Clegg railed against
the two-party Westminster stitch up and
now his viewed as part of the stitch up
himself the problem is the tuition fees
dramas drowned out many of the measures
the lib dems would rather this document
was remembered for they won't make the
same mistake again